-As summer winds down --
sorry, what are these...
empty Heineken cans
doing on my desk?
-Sorry. [Laughs]
I had an end-of-summer
desk party last night.
-Oh, hey, Ally.
What's a desk party?
-What do you think?
It's a party on your desk.
-Yeah, exactly -- my desk,
which you didn't clean up.
-I'm here to clean them up
and recycle them right now.
-I can't believe
you had a desk party,
which is totally not a thing,
by the way,
on my desk,
and didn't invite me.
-The desk isn't that big, Seth.
I had to make major cuts
to the guest list.
-How many people
could have possibly
come to this desk party?
-[ Coughs ]
Everyone on the crew.
-Everyone in the crew
but not me?
-Relax. We just had
Heineken 0.0s. No alcohol.
Here, to make amends,
I got you a regular lager.
-Hmm, well. Thank you.
Now, that's some good
desk party Heineken.
[ Clattering ]
I think you accidentally just
threw my jokes away.
-Oh, they weren't that good.
I wrote them last night
during the desk afterparty.
-How many desk parties
were there?
-Seth, I'm gonna level with you.
There's no such thing
as a desk party.
It's just called working.
-Right, I knew that.
Now get out of here
so I can work.
Now that is some good
solo desk party.